So the following video you're about to see is a talk I gave at the
district of the South's Annual conference that's a part of the Orthodox Church of America, and so
the reason why I'm making this introduction is because for those of you
who -- a lot of the videos that I've been making I've been making a big effort to speak with words that are
understandable to everyone, but in this particular talk
I was surrounded by priests and the Archbishop of the South, and so
possibly some of the words that are being used
will be difficult for people who are coming from the outside to understand, and so what I've done is I'm going to put a glossary
as close enough to a glossary of words in
the description for a few basic things, and
then I'm also going to try to add more images into the presentation so that it's as clear as possible for those who
who are chancing upon this. Oh, a last thing is that I've been receiving a lot of messages from people
who question whether or not the types of things I'm talking about
whether or not they're in line
let's say, with what actual Christians believe. A lot of people have been telling me that
that my version of Christianity is really nice, but that, you know, that's not what people in the church believe, and so I
Considering that, I would like you to ponder that I was surrounded by at least, what is it, 100
150 clergy, plus their wives and their families and the Archbishop of the South, and
although I'm sure some people didn't like my talk, no one was freaked out about what I was saying, and no one was
acting as if I was speaking completely against the tradition. So, having said all that, I present to you
Pentecost for the Zombie Apocalypse
Your Eminence and reverend fathers, I want to thank you for this opportunity
to speak to you
When I gave the title of my talk
I didn't know I would be speaking during the dinner,
and so it's just a rather awkward time to talk about zombies, so
so I decided I was going to spare you the grisly details, and
so I've chosen images that are
cartoons and from children's images, and so actually, although
they're meant to be whimsical and funny, they might be more frightening because that's what they're trying to be.
So, we live in a time of monsters.
I announce this to you, but I think all of you already know that.
We only need to glance at Popular Culture to realize this.
At the narrative level of our culture and our stories, we've become obsessed with monsters;
with the strange, aliens,
with the marginal, with the glorification of the exception,
of things that don't fit.
Most of us here probably grew up with
Sesame Street where we were told that "monsters are our friends"
and it's no longer in fiction by now
The Monsters
have left the dark spaces under our beds. They have left our nightmares to come out into the open.
At a social level we can feel and see all around us the growing polarization,
the acceleration of what we can only call the
the breakdown, the decomposition of culture,
a progressive dissipation of the center which rallies us as a society
and in thinking about this it's difficult not to
to reminisce - it's difficult not to
to meditate on the famous poem by Yeats
"The Second Coming"
And we tend to go back to that poem because it seems, at least in our more frightening moments,
we get the feeling that the horrific cycle of the 20th century is
on our horizon again.
Turning and turning in the widening gyre
The falcon cannot hear the falconer;
Things fall apart; the Center cannot hold
Mere anarchy is loosed upon the world
The blood-dimmed tide is loosed
and everywhere the ceremony of innocence is drowned
The best lack all conviction
While the worst are full of passionate intensity
This poem of which I've quoted the first part
Is probably one of the most known in modern poetry, the most cited; I think it's actually the most
anthologized poem there is
And it rings so true because we stand here in that widening, widening gyre
At the Edge of the world where the wheel is spinning so fast
it feels as if it's going to come off its axis
And it is here on the edge that we find the zombies
wandering aimlessly in a world that's losing its center
Unlike most of his monstrous brothers, let's say, the zombie is truly the harbinger of contemporary Nihilism.
The zombie has no magic.
The arrival of the zombie usually has no clear reason.
But rather, the zombie is couched in a biological accident: a disease, a plague.
It's simply an animated corpse.
The zombie inhabits the indeterminate space of living death.
Roaming around in packs, the zombie shows us the mindless wandering of the mindless mob
with an insatiable hunger for devouring others,
for swallowing life.
If the vampire is the monster of aristocracy
the zombie is the monster of the mass, of the demos;
the monster of the accidental, of quantitative leveling.
The zombie is the atheist insistent
on the illusion of free will.
It's an image of nihilism and an idiosyncrasy taken all the way to decomposition
In every major city in North America, they have these events
they call them "Zombie Walks"
and people dress up as zombies and walk in the thousands
down the streets dressed up and made up to look like corpses,
shifting around with dead empty eyes, pretending to be the Walking Dead.
Some of these are huge.
if we were generous
we could say that it is a zombie procession
We could call it
You could say that they're liturgical zombies, if there's such a thing.
The Zombie both typifies the Mob while simultaneously the absolute individualism,
the absolute isolation of contemporary life.
The zombies in a horde only interact with what they desire, and they never interact with each other.
And the trope of cannibalism is very ancient. It's there in all the ancient stories, all the ancient myths,
but the tweak, in zombies, on that theme:
of desiring to eat the brain
It's a very powerful one
Because it's truly the image of the nihilist, because the zombie is a creature without meaning, without intelligence.
It misses any form of personhood.
And it has this insatiable desire which mirrors what it lacks;
it desires what it lacks: identity, meaning.
And this desire appears in that materialist reduction
of identity and personhood to that clump of cells that we have up in our cranium.
The zombie wants to eat your brains, because it cannot eat the mind, and it cannot inhabit the mind.
But strangely enough, this desire to eat the living is the extreme
perversion of our desire for communion.
And it's also a distilled image of all our passions,
our attempt to fill the unquenchable yearning
through our passion, which always transforms other people into commodities that we think will bring us what we need.
So the zombie is both an image of the social breakdown
the person as a meaningless statistic,
the disappearance of common values, except the overwhelming desire to consume.
But so it is also the breakdown of the person itself into a soulless desiring death machine.
There's a strict analogy between these different levels of the world:
the social breakdown and polarization is to the State what the abandonment to the passions is for the Person.
And the zombie is both of those fragmentations at the same time.
So as we pull back a bit, as we look around,
as the narrative fabric of our world begins to fill in quantities that are barely possible to believe
with images of the monstrous
as we feel the world being torn apart by fragmentation and conflict
We are simultaneously as individuals being constantly
assaulted by images
images with the purpose of awakening our own desires.
And we've come to the point where we - most of us - so many of us have been accustomed
to the constant exposure to the stranger and stranger fringe of desire
while being enticed by the siren song to indulge,
to give in to the waves and the storm and to sink into the mire.
Now as we here, hopefully, who still hold on to a liturgical world
not the zombie kind, the divine kind
a world which strives out of pattern and purpose
We can both stand in a church where Christ, in the dome, is the origin of the heavenly hierarchy of beings
and we also know that we can find hesychia in our heart, in our center
as a gateway to the Divine,
and as the manager of the passions whirling in the widening gyre.
Just like our individual unholy unions with death appear on the edge of our beings
where, through an excessive attachment to our senses, we mingle with our passions and produce our own aberrations,
the Cosmic Monster lies on the Edge of the World,
the Edge and the End of the World
Those two things: the Edge and the End,
they represent the same structure. They're the same thing in our stories
and so even when he is a zombie, Man is the Microcosm.
The notion that a movement towards the Edge and a movement
towards the End have similar natures is one which is right there in the beginning of Scripture.
When Adam and Eve fall
they are told that they will die --
but that's not immediately what happens is it?
In fact, what happens is they move away from the central tree
past the Walls of the Garden, and out into the wilderness.
And similarly Adam, as he moves out from the center into history,
Adam and Eve are given garments of skin (Gen 3:21):
an outer layer of animality, an outer layer of death to protect them from death.
If our mind is struggling to
get a sense of what that means, it's very difficult to understand what that means
that we were given a protection of death
a layer of death to protect us from death.
I always think of a vaccine. It's probably the best image for that.
The garments of skin are seen by the Church Fathers as all that is added to our nature in the world of the fall,
the layers of society, of technology
and those are the flipside, and in a way,
they're of the same nature as our weakness, and the passions which come from the world of death.
St. Gregory of Nyssa tells us that the hairs on our body are a symbol of death.
They're without feeling and dead and appear as our spatial extremities,
the very limit of our garments of skin,
just as death appears as our temporal extremity of this earthly life.
The giants in the Bible,
those that appeared before the Flood
with a sign of confusion and mixture
wrapped in inappropriate sexual desire -
in the tradition of Enoch, they are seen as the origin of technology and magic, and they were known to create hybrids.
They're full of excess
reveling in conflict until absolute chaos could no longer be held at bay, and the world was undone in the waters
"The ceremony of Innocence was drowned"
in sophisticated hybrid non-binary fluid categories.
And in a very parallel way the ancients described the world geographically as a giant Island
surrounded by a vast ocean
whose fringes were inhabited by Impossible Monsters,
these signs of the breakdown and the confusion,
the confusion of categories, which is death
basically, the cosmic garments of skin.
These images that I'm showing you are based on the descriptions of the faraway races by
the first century Pliny the Elder, who died during the Vesuvius eruption
which destroyed Pompeii.
So now imagine how Pliny the Elder would have described these faraway specimens:
But I need to be careful because as we stand here possibly
in that widening gyre,
possibly nearing the teetering edge of the world,
it would be too easy to point and say, "There they are," right? "There they are,
the degenerate ones. There they are, the monsters, and thank God
we're safe in the church." And like I mentioned and like I'll be saying all through this talk:
the same chaos which lies on the Edge of the World also lies on the Edge of each one of us
But I think it's still possible though to look around and to read the signs of the time.
So how do we make sense of this? As we look around us and find the flood waters rising,
how do we navigate through the growing chaos?
In the back of my mind
there's a saying which plays over and over
maybe in the hopes of convincing myself, and it is the last promise made by Christ before his Ascension:
"Behold I am with you until the end of the age" (Mt 28:20)
And we know as Orthodox Christians that this promise
also implies that Christ is with us until the limits of the world,
with us until the bottom of the world, the bottom of death where Christ crushed the head of the serpent as
he descended into Hades.
The promise Christ made when he was about to ascend to the Father, the promise of Pentecost.
It echoes the promise of the Spirit that he made in the Gospel of St. John Chapter 14.
Pentecost is the possibility of
moving in Christ,
from the Upper Room,
from the top,
from the highest place, or from the center, let's say, no matter how you frame it, but to move in Christ until the
End of the World, until the End of the age.
It is the Church ablaze, a fire that spreads and consumes until the age itself.
It consumes, but like the fire that Moses saw on Sinai, the Church is not consumed.
The icon of Pentecost is a cosmic image
It shows us a type of multiplicity, which is not fragmentation,
a type of multiplicity which is not the decomposition of our times
but is a multiplication which does not forget its center.
In the terms of the Philokalia
as we move into multiplicity, Pentecost is the possibility of the remembrance of God,
the remembrance of God even unto death.
If we look at the image, we see the icons are seated in an arch,
which is a proxy of the church itself
The icon of Pentecost is one of those icons which,
although it does represent an event in the Bible, it represents it in a manner that goes beyond the event and
becomes a permanent image of how the Church exists in the world
and the hint that this is the case is that although St. Paul was not there at the
event of the Bible, he is represented in this icon and here, St. Peter and
St. Paul are represented together as the pillars of the Church
as the left hand and right hand of Christ
Above the Apostles is the Holy Fire which descends on them
This fire separates into twelve, just as the Apostles themselves each acquired
tongues of fire
tongues which speak in a manner that can reveal Christ through
multiplicity and be heard by all men.
And then, down in the bottom of the icon is the door which leads outside the Upper Room,
it is the door which leads out into the outer darkness
And in the door is represented the allegorical figure of the Cosmos itself, which holds the scrolls, the fully manifest
form of the twelve traditions issued by the one fire, the one Church whose unity is preserved in its multiplicity
And, of course, the door of Pentecost is the door of the Church itself,
the Church considered at all levels of
interpretation that we can understand that statement. It's both the door of the Church in the sense of the cosmic body of Christ
but it's also the door on the building of your local church, the door which leads out of the nave, out of the narthex
into the chaotic outside.
Now in earlier traditions of Pentecost
what was represented in the door was not the synthetic image of Cosmos, and the very earliest images
that I could find in this form of Pentecost - they all come from right after Iconoclasm and
they represent an empty door
but very soon in the door was represented a crowd of foreigners,
all with different hats and different clothing  and different shades of skin color.
This is one of my favorite versions:
It's from a Serbian monastery, and here the door of Pentecost is actually a window
which leads outside of the church,
and the foreigners appear coming towards the Church from the edge, on the sides.
There's a tradition from Armenia which portrays a monster in the door of Pentecost.
The monster is either a dog-headed man,
a cynocephalus,
or else it is truly
an unnameable monster, a kind of chaotic being
with a dog-face growing behind its head.
This was the image that I chose as the first slide of my presentation.
Now the first time I saw this image, I came across it in a book and I was startled
beyond belief
I mean, I guess you can imagine.
But as I began to understand the image of Pentecost
I realized to what extent this is a testimony to the totality of what Christianity is meant to be,
to the true possibility of God being all in all.
The monster, as an inhabitant of the margin, is a token of that which does not fit
within what we know, cannot be measured in the
categories that we are aware of, it appears as a freak, as the ultimate Unexpected.
So, the monster is both the encounter with the surprise of the future as we move forward in time
(so to encounter the unexpected), but the monster is also the encounter with the surprise of the Edge,
as the Church expands into the dark corners of the world, but also the dark corners of our own lives.
As the Spirit of God transforms us, for most of us there will always be
foreign elements, monsters hiding in our garments of skin.
So here, in Pentecost, this monster is represented as not yet in the Church,
but as part of the potential into which the Church can grow,
as part of that which can hear the gospel in its language
Now I want to issue -- before I keep going -- I want to issue a caveat if there are some
cryptozoologists in the room, or like conspiracy types who talk about Lizard Men who live under the earth
Like, you don't have to identify yourself, but this next part is for you.
We have to be extremely careful when we read ancient accounts.
We don't want to interpret them in rather materialistic categories of genus and species.
In the Bible, a bird is an animal with wings. So a bat is a bird.
And a fish is something in the water, so whales and dolphins are fish.
And so we don't have to imagine some kind of cynocephalic people out there that would have some genetic
relationship to dogs
anymore than we used to think that a hippo-potamus, or a "river horse," need have a genetic relationship with horses.
Just as the ancient called those they could not understand
"barbarians," that is, those who bark like dogs,
The notion of dog-headed man appears as this encounter
with an aspect of humanity which we can barely see because they're
so far removed from our capacity to properly see them.
If I hear someone speaking Cantonese, I am not going to understand - I will hear chaos.
And it's difficult to have that experience now because we've seen everything. But if you just maybe imagine seeing
an Australian Bushman 500 years ago,
it is possible to see chaos.
But the notion of the cynocephalus has an important history in Christianity.
It comes, of course, from the
Hellenic past, from the legends of Alexander the Great.
But the image of the dog-headed man became the central image of the Christian Edge of the world,
the ultimate hostile Foreigner.
Personally, I think that it partly became so important because of its strong analogies in the Bible.
Christ speaks to the Canaanite woman
and he tells her that one should not give to dogs the bread that is meant for the children (Mt 15:26)
and the answer of the Canaanite woman
is analogous to what we see in this icon,
that "even the dogs eat the crumbs that fall from their master's table."
So here in the icon of Pentecost, we see this dog not so much at the end of the table
but maybe on the Edge of the Church, maybe on the Edge of the World.
This one is not a Canaanite,
but a Caninite.
That might seem like a really bad pun
but I assure you that
it will cause modern interpreters to cry foul in reading these ancient accounts, and will say that all of this
question is just a matter of bad transcription.
I don't think so.
All these foreigners in the icon of Pentecost,
culminating into the impossible monster, are the surprise we discover on the Edge of the Church
anticipating, maybe waiting for the crumbs, maybe waiting for the antidoron (blessed bread),
which we can imagine flowing out of the Church,
so that even those we can barely recognize as our brothers can have a foretaste of the Kingdom of Heaven.
Now the most famous dog-headed man
some of you know where I'm going with this
is, of course, St. Christopher.
St. Christopher's traditional icon represents him as a dog-headed warrior.
There are many who have tried to say that this tradition of St. Christopher as a dog-headed man
is late, and like I said, is just a misunderstanding of ancient texts, and
I don't know, it depends what you mean by "late."
This is the first image of St. Christopher we have; it's from the 6th or the 7th century.
So it's before iconoclasm, which means that we're lucky we even have this image
There are probably many more, but they've just been destroyed by the Iconoclasts.
It's a ceramic icon depicting him next to St. George, each killing snakes.
And this is just one of my favorite images in the world.
So here's the the Monster and Monster Killer - two warriors facing the dragons.
And it's funny how they they keep telling us that the legend of St. Christopher
killing the dragon is from the 12th century or something.
It always seems like scholars are telling Christians that we're deluding ourselves
and that a world cannot exist without a textual reference.
But here it is.
So there was an attempt to eliminate this icon in the Russian synodal period
because it did not fit modern sensibilities, and I've had many people, especially priests, tell me that
they're really bothered by this icon and
It's funny because, although I have tried to explain it, and in a certain manner, defend it.
For example, I wrote an article about St. Christopher in the Orthodox Arts Journal, and it is one of our most popular articles.
It has been viewed over 20,000 times.
When an article about a dog-headed Saint is one of your most popular articles,
I would call that a sign of the times, people
But having said that I would be a bit disturbed myself
if we were not at least bothered by this icon -- I mean my goodness! it is a dog headed man, after all.
And I think that, in a way, that that's the point.
I think that that's the point.
I always like to say that St. Christopher, the icon of St. Christopher is the "Last Icon."
It's on the very edge of iconography and because it is so, it will always appear as ambiguous
and straddle the border of what is acceptable or unacceptable in icons.
In the Greek tradition, the icon of St. Christopher was actually placed above the exit door of the church
so that it would be the last thing you saw
going out into the world
And in the west, St. Christopher was placed on bridges
where he would represent the uneasy space of the transition, the in-between space.
I think St. Christopher is
crucially important to understand right now.
Basically, I think that St. Christopher is the Patron Saint of the End of the World.
And although he's not my official patron, I would say that he's become so unofficially.
Having lived abroad for many years
and having traveled much I've witnessed many miracles and I've seen many signs surrounding his presence in my life.
So this is one of the icons that hangs in my workshop.
And also, I think that we'll need St. Christopher when the zombies come.
So as we face the rising chaos, as we face the zombies, we recall  the words of the Psalmist,
"I am surrounded by my enemies who are like lions hungry for human flesh" (Ps 57:4)
The immediate danger is that we become afraid, like St. Peter walking on the waters.
There's a trope in zombie stories,
according to which, no matter how bad the situation is, no matter how hard the zombies try to get in,
the true danger lies within
the true danger lies in how the human group
shuts themselves off, and completely isolates themselves, and become pathological in their isolation.
The fear of facing the possibility of the flood is to think that, as in the story of Noah,
the door of the Church must be closed and sealed shut.
Maybe we can get together and isolate ourselves completely. I mean, it's tempting isn't it?
And we've heard some intimations of that tendency recently.
But Christ promised us that the gates of hell will not prevail on the doors of the church
And I'm not saying here there isn't a time to seal the door of the church. Obviously, that's what we do, at least symbolically,
after the exit of the catechumens
We should, and must, protect our Mysteries.
In fact, it rather seems sometimes that we've been sheepish in doing so.
I want to show you something.
Once I encountered an image of Pentecost from a medieval Coptic church.
Can you see the difference?
It was the first time I saw an icon of Pentecost where the door was closed and
it disturbed me profoundly to see such an image.
And it took time before I understood why such an image would even have come into existence
I realized, at least I speculated, that the Copts had become so beset on all sides
by their opponents,
had been so besieged in their dhimmi status (subjection under Islam),
that it was inevitable that they represent the door of Pentecost as closed.
It's food for thought.
But to see such an image should make us weep and pray
that even as we become besieged we find a way to keep the door of Pentecost open, for if we close those doors
we abandon the world to its fragmentation.
I want to tell you the story of St. Christopher.
You've all heard it.
I want to tell it, maybe in a different way.
The version of the story which we know best actually comes from the western tradition.
In the western tradition, St. Christopher is not a dog-headed man, but a giant.
He's not a Caninite, but a Caananite,
and, in an important way,  he's a Cainite,
that is a descendant of Cain who associated with the nephilim, the giants of the Genesis Flood.
So although he's not a dog-headed man in the western tradition,
and some people have felt safe and represented this version of
the icon in their churches because they didn't like the dog-headed version - and that's understandable -
But even though he's a Cainite, St. Christopher is still like the Canaanite woman,
the "dog on the edge of the table" who asks Christ for the crumbs.
So, as hard as you try, you will not get the dog out of St. Christopher
These are a few hybrid icons, joining the western tradition with the eastern one.
The story of St. Christopher has him as a vicious warrior in Canaan who is looking to serve the most powerful man in the world.
He found the most renowned and powerful king, until he sees that this king is afraid of the devil.
So he goes to serve the devil.
And in this we can see St. Christopher going all the way to the end, all the way
to the edge of what is imaginable, in becoming a servant of the evil one directly.
Then St. Christopher notices that the evil one is afraid of the Cross, so he decides he will serve Christ.
And when the story, at least in the version that's in the Golden Legend, Saint Christopher is also a trickster
because he tells those he serves, for example, he informs the king that
unless the king tells him who the devil is, that he will no longer serve that king.
But in answering St. Christopher, this becomes the very
reason why Saint Christopher stops serving the king, and then looks for the next most powerful
person, which is the devil.
And then, he does the same to the devil: he tricks the devil himself
to reveal Christ to him.
We need to pay attention to this detail, because
I think it's an image of what St. Christopher can be for us, the key to
the double inversion, which transforms the Fall and Death into Resurrection, the "trampling of death by death."
In his search for Christ he comes to a hermit in the desert who teaches him the way of Christianity.
But when it comes to the practice, St. Christopher cannot follow the rule,
cannot follow the standard. I mean he is a monster, after all.
The Hermit says to fast, to abstain.
St. Christopher replies that he cannot.
The Hermit says to pray.
St. Christopher says he cannot.
So the hermit says that St. Christopher should stand next to the river and
cross those who need to cross on his shoulders.
I want you to notice how
profound the story becomes here
We often think of the Ark built by Noah as a holy thing and, in a certain way, it is.
We often imagine the nave, or even the whole church as a holy thing, and in many ways, it is.
But in another very, very important way, the ark is a boat full of beasts.
And the Church is a hospital full of the sick.
So, since Christopher stands on the Edge of the world, he stands on the bank of the Flood,
when the Logos the Christ Emmanuel, who is the Logos implicit, the seed of God in all things,
comes to the edge,
well, it is the monster, like an Ark, who can carry him across.
I want you to think of that hermit.
You see, the hermit did not tell St. Christopher
that it was fine that he could not follow fasting and prayer.
I mean, he didn't say that, since St. Christopher
thought that it was against his nature to fast and pray the hermit didn't tell him that the Church had been wrong all along.
No
But the hermit,
in wisdom and in economía, he brought St. Christopher to the edge,
he brought St. Christopher into the narthex, on the Edge of the Flood,
where he could be the ambiguous figure he was in the first place,
and eventually, and mysteriously, become a vehicle for his Lord.
There's a woman who comes to our parish. Her name is Margeline.
Margeline is homeless,
and if sometimes she's able to find a place to stay it never lasts long
She's never able to find stability. There's something - some thrust - in her which makes it impossible to remain stable.
Generous people from the parish have tried to help her find a place, to help her find some stability, but
it never lasts long.
Margeline is a hermaphrodite.
Her appearance is confusing,
as she straddles the limits of what we understand, straddles the limits of the normal categories
that constitute the world.
Margeline is paranoid,
and possibly more: when you speak with her she jumps from one thing to the next, one subject to the next.
Her conversation is disjointed and fragmented;
to speak with her is to feel like she's constantly under attack.
Margeline comes and sits in the narthex, and she usually stays there for the whole service.
And very rarely, she gets up and she walks into the nave and she sits down in the nave,
but she always stays just for a few minutes, and then she returns to the narthex.
We've invited her to come in,
our priest has spoken to her, asked her if she wanted to be catechized, if she wanted to join,
and join into full communion,
but Margeline returns to the narthex.
She waits until coffee hour, she eats with us, and hopes that someone will give her some money
before she leaves.
Margeline has memorized the services.
Sometimes she makes little comments about some detail,
you know, some small error or confusion in the service.
Maybe the choir was off a little bit. Maybe someone forgot some small detail.
And she knows what's happening in the parish,
the politics and the jostling which sometimes takes place in human affairs.
And we hear strands of that, we hear these hyper-lucid
comments - they appear as surprises - in her usual frenetic conversation.
One Sunday, Margeline reached into her backpack.
She carries this backpack around with her, and she reached into her backpack and she took out
these three small McDonald toys, you know, the kind of toy you get if you buy a Happy Meal.
She took these three toys, and she gave them to my children.
There's a tradition in Indian culture, according to which to receive a gift from a beggar
is to receive a blessing from God.
There are those who whisper in the parish, I don't know who,
but there's someone whispering in the parish that, maybe, Margeline is an angel.
Once, in speaking to her, she told me that she also attends a mosque,
that there is a Muslim couple who will often pick her up on Friday so that she can participate in the prayer.
So, I would ask all of you
in that last sentence that I just added to that story, all of us to examine what our hearts did
when I added that last part
There are some of us here who might be too happy
that I mentioned the detail about the mosque, and there are some here
who might be too annoyed that I mentioned that detail.
But Margeline just sits in the narthex, after all.
There's something about the margin
which always arouses our passions.
And so I hope that I brought all of you to a place that you're struggling to deal with...
The threat of zombies, the abundance of monsters, St. Christopher, dog-headed men, people who don't fit into categories.
If you feel uneasy and a bit conflicted and confused that I was able to move from zombies to angel in one fell swoop,
I'm sorry. I have to apologize. That was really the point of my talk.
That's what fragmenting looks like, that's what a fragmented age looks like:
the moment when order is not easy to inhabit because the world is filled with exceptions.
There's something deeply out of place that I am here at a church conference talking about zombies.
But that's where we are.
That's where we are in the world.
If we think we can deal with this age by simply shutting the door of the church we are going to be in serious trouble.
And if we think we can deal with this age by letting in the flood waters there is going to be serious trouble, as well.
So now, what do we do? How do we live? How do we love properly in an age of division and chaos?
First, I think we need to look at the icon of Pentecost with some humility.
The chaos of the Edge and the End is death.
But chaos is also an opportunity for renewal.
This was true for the Sabbath, it is true for Baptism, and it is true for Holy Saturday
and, for goodness sake, it's true when we sleep.
Most of us here are here today because the rigid categories which legislate society are breaking down.
They've been breaking down for about three generations. If I if I were to ask everyone here what their ancestry is,
how many are immigrants, or children of immigrants
I mean, we are standing here in a
in a church which came from Russia and here we are in the south of the United States.
I am a French-Canadian Protestant who became an Orthodox icon carver.
We are the image of the opportunity of Pentecost.
I mean, would this gathering here have even been possible 50 years ago?
No, there's no way.
We can be here because, in the breakdown of categories,
things that usually would not meet can in fact meet.
And I believe it's not for nothing that Christianity increased in the twilight of the Roman Empire, where the stretched
multi-ethnic, multicultural vastness was oscillating between fragmentation, civil war, and the iron fist of a Diocletian figure.
But here's the kicker - here is the side effect, the surprising side effect of our fragmentation
Right now, as we are watching the western world being propped up as competing
identities of race and gender,
you know, and ethnicity and age and, you name it, any identity you can imagine
and while simultaneously, there's this paradoxical
insistence that all identities and distinctions have to be dissolved,
there are those who are not even in the church not in any church who are getting an inkling that, maybe,
Christianity, considered even at its minimum as a set of presuppositions,
maybe it was the only glue that ever held the west together.
That ever kept the balance
since the conversion of Rome, even as precarious
and volatile as that unity sometimes was.
And so I've been surprised to find myself
facing all these people, these atheists, these people who don't believe in anything
who are suddenly looking at Christianity and Christian presuppositions.
But, of course, the same breakdown, let's make no
Illusion about this, the same breakdown of society which makes this meeting possible,
which makes some see that Christianity is valuable, is also the breakdown which
makes the zombie scratch at our door.
And it seems that every exception, every aberration, every
proclivity is looking for its moment in the sun, looking not only to exist in the margin,
but to be given the stamp of full official recognition.
But in the rising flood, in the world filled with monsters,
people are looking for meaning,
people are so hungry for meaning.
For the past year or so I have been on an adventure, on a crazy adventure that took me completely by surprise.
I was asked to do some interview with some professor in Toronto on some random subject,
and because of that, I'm not going to go into the details,  but all of a sudden
I was being flooded with letters and letters of atheists,
atheists who are looking around and are seeing
the fragmentation as well. They're looking around and they're seeing the hemorrhaging of our culture
and they're trying to ask, "What can we do to stop the bleeding?"
a long email every day of some recovering atheist,
who's moving away from their criticism
you know, of the 13-year-old's version of Christianity, and is discovering the cosmic vision of Christ.
He's discovering the cosmic vision of his Mother whose womb is vaster than the heavens.
There's so much to say to those people.
I mean, we hold in our hearts the tradition of Christ which connects, through a beautiful braid of analogies, the personal,
the social, the cosmic, and the Transcendent realms.
I have not tried to convince anybody. I have no desire to convince anybody.
The only thing that I ever did was to show people
the beautiful patterns that are in our Tradition, the beautiful connections between Scripture and the icons and the liturgy and the hymns and
people are so hungry for meaning that they just
It's like breathing. It's like it's like all the sudden. They've been drowning and they can
they can take a breath. I'm not saying that all these people are going to become Orthodox. I mean I don't think so.
But it's a crazy thing I got a letter from a man from 2-3 days ago
I got a letter from a man in Pakistan.
a man who was a Muslim and who in university like so many people became an atheist
and now he writes me, and he says,
"I think I'm a Christian. I don't know and I don't know what to do
because I'm in Pakistan."
Of all the Christians, we do not see the stories of the Bible, the stories of salvation, as just this arbitrary set
of facts that we must believe in to be saved.
Of all Christians, we know the organic process of salvation, the transformation of man into God
through participation in the life of God, is the very manner by which the world exists.
It's the very thing that links these outward phenomena to consciousness, to Nous, to Logos
and unites all things towards the Infinite.
I mean, how awesome is that?
And in the background we've also kept and we hold, not only the keys to Christianity,
we also hold the heritage of the ancients. I mean, we're not
Platonists, but we have carried Plato. We are not
Aristotelian, but we have carried Aristotle, Alexander, Homer, Virgil, and we could add to that,
you know, all the useful stories of all people who enter in communion with Christ.
We keep them alive in the narthex of the church so that they can participate in
the manner in which it is possible that they participate in the divine life.
You'll recognize these are images of the Greek sages from a narthex at a monastery in Greece.
They don't have halos, so it's okay.
We hold the golden thread that reaches back into the mists of time,
the same golden thread that is under increasing threat of being cut.
So I think the chaos we face is a test, like the waters of baptism it will wash off all that is
superficial, all that which we have not integrated.
Encountering the outer darkness, being challenged by the outer darkness is an urgent test for Christians to know
to the extent that it is possible to know in our hearts and our minds, What exactly is this thing about?
What is the Incarnation? How does it anchor the world? And, of course, there is Mystery.
But we can tell people why Mystery matters.
Why some things cannot be described or contained, and why that Mystery is the fount of existence.
And I think that the answer in how to engage the fragmenting world, is in the story of Saint Christopher.
But as we travel farther away from the altar, we never compromise its purity.
As we move to the nave and through the narthex,
as we move out in a candlelit procession, out into the world,
our compassion grows as Christ's compassion grew
facing the adulterous woman. As Christ's compassion grew facing the rich, thieving tax collector, the heretical
Samaritan woman. All of this we can do without
compromising the purity of the altar, the rigor of the sacramental life.
Christ protected the purity of the Holy Place, he cleared the temple of lies and corruption,
and Christ can hold a whip in his left hand and
bless with his right hand.
We need not confuse the altar with the narthex
and, in fact, we offer that very structure to the world, the very structure of the Church itself as a ladder,
And we're willing to plant that first bar
plant it unapologetically into the mud.
maybe into the very belly of hell,
but we know that it reaches all the way to the Heaven of Heavens.
But,
as we preserve the
hierarchy of salvation, we must remain cautious.
We must remain humble enough to notice
the Holy Fool
who's hiding in the chaos,
the exception who reminds us that
hierarchy is for us, and not for God,
who is beyond all distinction.
We need to be humble enough to perceive that sometimes,
even if it is rarely, by the grace of our Lord, the monster on the Edge of the World
will be the very vehicle for Christ to be carried farther out than we ever thought possible.
Thank you.
(Whistle)